- Et là, il m'a agrippée,
et là, les mains dans le dos,
qui sont descendues quand même
assez basses; assez envahissant
pour quelqu'un qui est mon
supérieur, qui est l'archevêque
de Québec.
- Cette femme, qui souhaite
protéger son identité,
était agente de pastorale
stagiaire au diocèse de Québec,
entre 2008 et 2010.
À plusieurs occasions,
le cardinal Ouellet aurait
posé des gestes inappropriés
à son endroit.
- Ça allait comme un peu
en gradation, en augmentant.
C'était de plus en plus
ant, de plus en plus
intense.
- Massage des épaules,
caresse dans le dos jusqu'aux
fesses, étreintes,étreintes,étr;
des contacts intrusifs
qui la rendaient mal à l'aise.
- J'avais l'impression,
des fois, qu'il me pourchassait
au point où je me suis mise à
arrêter d'aller aux événements,
essayer le plus possible
en sa présence.
- Elle est aujourd'hui
une des requérantes
de l'action collective autorisée
e diocèse de Québec.
Et tous ses propos coïncident
avec le contenu de la requête.
Entre autres, lorsqu'elle ose
parler de son malaise, on répond
que le cardinal est...
- Un homme chaleureux
en autorité comme il l'était
à l'époque, ce n'est paschaleur.
- Selon un des avocats
qui intentent le recours,
les gestes reprochés
au cardinal Ouellet peuvent peut
sembler moins graves que ceux
posés par d'autres, mais ils
ne doivent pas être banalisés.
Me ALAIN ARSENAULT,
représentant des demandeurs
- Ce n'est pas le nombre,
ce n'est pas le type d'agression
qui est important, c'est
les conséquences, les séquelles.
Et c'est ça qu'il faut évaluer.
Il est difficileifficileifficilr
qu'une personne de
son intelligence, dans
un positionnement dans lequel
il est, qu'il ne pouvait pas
ignorer ce qu'il faisait
et les conséquences
que ça pouvait avoir.
- La jeune femme n'osait pas
dénoncer son patron.
- C'était celui qui, au boutde ,
allait signer si oui ou non
mon contrat de... comme mandater
comme agente de pastorale.
- Vous avez là, à ce moment-là,
une jeune femme, disons,
mi-vingtaine, versus un homme
puissant, une autorité connue
ment à l'époque,
qui avait peut-être 60 ans.
Elle a figé, comme beaucoup
de victimes; comme la majorité
des victimes, elle a figé.
- Les incidents auraient pris
fin en 2010 lorsque Marc Ouellet
est rappelé à Rome et nommé
préfet de la Congrégation
pour les évêques.
C'est après avoir vécu
une expérience éprouvante
impliquant un deuxième prêtre
que la requérante contacte
le Comitdu diocèse
de Québec pour les abus sexuels,
en 2020.
- J'ai abordé le comité
un peu en leur disant :
"Bien, je ne sais pas si
j'ai été victime, mais voici
mon histoire." Et j'avais senti
le besoin de relater tout ce que
j'avais vécu d'inapproprié
depuis mes débuts
comme agente de pastorale.
- Elle a situation
sans le nommer au Comité conseil
et le Comité conseil du diocèse,
à bout d'un certain nombre
de temps, a dit : "Oui, oui,c'e"
Et c'est là qu'elle a dit
au Comité conseil :
"C'est l Ouellet."
- La plainte envers le cardinal
Ouellet se rend directement
à Rome; elle est  père
Jacques Servais. Une rencontre
par visioconférence a lieu
avec l'émissaire du Vatican.
Un an plus tard, lte
attend toujours ses conclusions.
Le diocèse de Québec dit
prendre acte des allégations à
l'endroit du cardinal Ouellet,
mais qu'il ne fera strictement
aucun commentaire.
Ici Sylvie Fournier,
Radio-Canada, Mon